good morning everyone it's a nice effect
just to bring attention to another cool
so my name is Chris Ford I work for a
company called thought weds who were
present at Strange Loop if you want to
check them out and I've always wanted to
well I guess like many people I've been
interested in books that explain big
ideas to me and often what I wanted is
I've read that book I got so excited
that what I really wanted to do is just
basically sit down a roomful of people
and just talk with them about it for
like about 40 minutes so I guess today
my dream has come true so so this book
is called African Philippa knee and
polyrhythm and the talk is basically a
programmers response to this this book
so the book is what you might call an
ethnomusicology book and so you might
say well what how is that different from
any other kind of musicology and I guess
traditionally what that meant was it was
the study of music from cultures other
than Western cultures that's certainly
got better throughout the 20th century
so now maybe the discipline will be
better thought of as the study of music
within a particular culture so this book
is by Professor Sinha Aram here's a
famous ethnomusicologist but he started
out being trained within the European
musical tradition so he won first prize
for French horn in the Parisian
conservatory so this is someone with
kind of serious credentials from the
European way of looking at music and
then in I think was 1963 professor Aram
not a professor then travelled to the
Central African Republic so this is
about three years after the Central
African Republic gained its independence
from France and he was going there to
help establish a brass band I guess this
is the idea of some kind of cultural
exchange but it turned out he arrived
the day before the National Independence
Day of the Central African Republic
which is on the 1st of December so he
waits and gets to his hotel wakes up the
next morning and the capital Bangui is
full of music all sorts of music and
music of a kind that professor aram had
never
really heard before so you could tell it
was amazing and in the book he describes
it as lovers first sight and I guess
this particular encounter with this
music changed his career but he didn't
really know what kind of music it wasn't
he didn't really have the background to
understand it so here's some examples of
the kind of music from the very varied
traditions of a Central African Republic
but a rom encountered so groups of
percussion instruments playing tightly
interlocked rhythms so that's what kind
of polyrhythm comes in the title of the
book and orchestras are up to 20 wind
instruments where each musician plays
only a single note so there's just a
single pitched instrument but the
orchestra is a hole plays melodies based
on musicians understanding exactly when
they need to play within the hole and
choirs singing incredibly complex yet
perfectly perfectly coherent
contrapuntal music so what I'm gonna do
today with a little bit more background
is I'm gonna synthesize examples of the
first two kinds of music I'm not gonna
show you an example of the third kind
but I will explain why I won't just as a
bit of attention to to lead you on so a
ROM says he was conditioned by a
cultural background to narrow to allow
easy comprehension of this music and so
he could tell it was wonderful he could
tell it was rich and complex and worthy
of his study but he had trouble
situating it against his traditional
European background at the time so when
he came to come back to the Central
African Republic as an ethnomusicologist
he was trying to find about ways of
taking these wonderful orchestral pieces
or large ensemble pieces and kind of
breaking them down so he could analyze
them in terms that could make sense to
him so one of the the cool innovations
that Iran came up with was to use the
playback recording technique that's
often used in western popular music so
the trouble you've got is that if you
have a single musician playing a melody
someone whose skill can write that down
right they can notate it they can listen
hear what the notes are up and down
maybe they'll make a mistake but it's
it's kind of tractable to an ordinary
human musician but if you have 20
instruments playing at once different
pitch
interlocking in complex ways it's not
really a practical thing we're human
year doesn't scale that well so what he
did was he wanted to recall the musician
separately but the trouble he ran into
was that these musicians weren't used to
playing their parts individually it kind
of was like having one side of a
conversation without the other it wasn't
really how they used to experience in
the music they used to playing off that
the other musician so what he did was he
recorded the ensemble as a whole and
then used headphones to allow individual
musicians to just play just their part
so he could recall that separately but
as he notes in the book it's not really
that taking a part of things into
individual pieces that was a hard bit he
would did that and it was kind of fine
but what he really wanted to do was find
out what were the principles by which
these parts came together to form this
music and in the book as well as talking
about the specifics of the Central
African Republic's music he also talks a
lot about the methodology of doing this
kind of thing so this realization Eero
model a low arrow realization is a
schematic that he introduces in the book
and basically the idea is that if you
have a performance or a realization and
then you can produce some kind of
simplified model of it and then use that
to produce another performance if the
thing that you produce from the model
sounds okay sounds authentic sounds
reasonable then you've got a reasonable
assurance that the way you modeled it in
the middle was okay so if the
realizations on either side of the model
at the same structural features you've
got proof that your model is coherent
the trouble is of course this is a
subjective thing because you will get
something slightly different so you need
someone who's a bearer of that tradition
of music to say whether or not the
output is authentic or whether it's
rubbish basically and in the case of the
way a ROM was doing things in generally
in musicology and ethnomusicology the
way you model things is using western
music notation so use a score that's
that's what the model is made of mostly
so I assume probably a lot of people may
have encountered it but basically it's a
system of you putting dots on a stave
and how high the dot is tells you how
high the pitches and where it is
horizontally tells you when the note
and so it's kind of quite a literal data
format for turning music into notes on
the page but from a programmers point of
view you might be able to say that this
actually has two purposes one of which
is to allow the person who's notating
the music to express themselves and the
other is to allow the musician is
playing the music to understand and play
it so this kind of dual purpose it does
pretty well but there are some
weaknesses in it which I'll discuss a
bit later so one way you can think of
modeling in general is as compression so
JPEG is one way of understanding how
images look like so you could say that
using a JPEG on a flat image that has a
sharply defined lines and clear color
palettes that's going to be in an
appropriate way of modeling that image
and when you expand it again and when
you display the image again you're gonna
get compression artifacts and that's
actually a problem for these models of
ethnomusicology as well that you've
really got to try hard to defy it cite
what is relevant so you want to make
sure your model has everything that's
relevant about the music in it that you
haven't dropped everything anything
that's relevant and you haven't
introduced any kind of artifacts or
extra stuff that isn't supposed to be
there so this idea of relevance is
something that Ron talks about quite a
bit and it's not that dissimilar to I
guess trying to produce a scientific
model of a phenomenon you want to make
sure that your laws explain it and that
don't add anything extra there's an
example in the book that ROM talks about
over maybe you know you could say an
earlier musicologist ethnomusicologist
called bela bartok quite a famous
composer
so what Bartok did was he was Hungarian
and he went and did an investigation of
the folk music of his country so the
classical music is well known but there
were a lot of really interesting scales
and intricacies of Hungarian folk music
that folks hadn't been paying attention
to previously and what he did was he you
know he did recordings he made models of
it he you know he he brought it to a
wider audience but there's still a bit
of a slightly problematic thing about
this process where you know it took the
blessing of a kind of an art a Western
art music composer
looking at this music for people to
regarded as interesting and the other I
guess tricky thing is that Bartok used
these really interesting folk musics to
inspire his classical compositions but
it's his name that's known right not the
name of the original musicians that
provided him with the source material so
it's kind of a great thing that he did
but on the other hand there is a bit of
a slight uncomfortable taste of
appropriation about about some of this
which I'll come back to later
so one example of a compression artifact
in modeling other musical traditions is
Bartok's B semi flat so when he was
listening to these folk musicians he he
encountered what he thought was a real
phenomenon of a note between B and
b-flat and so he no tailor with B / -
but when other Hungarian musicians went
back to the source material later on
they found it wasn't really a real
phenomenon
that there was various notes of various
different pitches it wasn't really a
real thing so when Bartok was notating
with this his B semi-flat it was
something that he'd he'd introduced it
was basically a compression artifact in
his understanding of the music so we
want to avoid that as we try to explain
other musics so a ROM came to a broad
understanding of what Central African
music or many of its forms hears which
is ostinato with variations so ostinatos
are fairly a fancy music theoretic term
basically meaning repetition so
repetition with variations that's the
principle at which a lot of these musics
are based and all the ones that I'll
show you today are so each musician
basically has their own part which they
kind of play over and over again that
interlocks with the parts of every other
musician and they introduce variation
over time but the the complexity of the
music comes I guess you might say
vertically rather than horizontally so a
lot of western music it's going
somewhere right it has a beginning a
middle and end it might set up a tension
and later resolver what the Central
African music does to have interest and
complexity is more vertical so you have
a fairly short motif that's going round
and round and cycling but within that
there's an immense amount of variation
and
just so I when I read this I heard well
repetition and variation these are these
are things that programming can do
pretty well right we know how to repeat
things over and over again we know how
to introduce changes we know how to make
models come alive we know how to make
mathematical models into running
programs so maybe this is something that
we can do with the musical theory of
Iran and then I read this bit which
almost felt like an invitation to do so
it's slightly sexist phrasing by
basically a Roman saying well if the
reader wants to use the transcriptions
to construct polyrhythmic formulae if we
respect the rules of the grammar go
ahead no it was an invitation right
there on the page was back then he goes
on to say that the combinations should
be perfectly acceptable to bearers of
the tradition so Ron's making the claim
that his models of the music are kind of
sufficiently good that even if it's a
bit wonky what comes out the other side
should be authority authentic enough
that someone from the app a tribe or
someone who's a band alinder person
should be able to recognize it as music
from that tradition and then I remember
the quote at the start of the book which
seemed almost more clearly like an
invitation which is from the famous
anthropologist Levi Strauss that the
proof of the analysis is in the
synthesis rhyme so let's get
synthesizing
and so so the first thing I'm going to
do is model a piece that is called a
Gerta Remo and I'm sure I'm
mispronouncing it like all good people
who learn things from books rather than
conversation but it's it's right I'm
sure probably a lot of people in the
rooms encountered that as well but it's
a programmatic model of a piece of music
that in the book is captured by using
western music notation the dots so argot
room is a drum piece consisting of three
drums so there's the child drum the
highest one and the way that drums part
works is there's an underlying model and
there's a bunch of variations on it so a
ROM kind of goes and lists these out
longhand but I think we can do a bit of
a better job because we're programmers
so if I just look at this rhythm here
I'm representing it enclosures data
structure so it's kind of just think of
it like Jason and you won't go far wrong
and it consists of three notes only one
that happens at time zero of duration
two-fifths ever be a next one that has a
duration of three fifths and then
finally one that has five fifths or one
so there's this a regional model and
then we have a bunch of different
functions that we apply to the model to
produce the different variations so each
variation is just a function of what
you've done to the base model of the
music to produce produce that particular
instantiation of the pattern so we've
just created a couple of functions that
are customized to this kind of music so
we're able to create new symbols create
new subroutines because this is
programming they just splits two notes
in in in half or rather splits a note at
5/5 splitting 1/5 of a beat off the
front of it and another one at the note
at six fifths so basically what we've
done is we've produced a model of how
this music functions we've produced this
concept of splitting beads and then if
we this won't be readable so don't worry
but what it effectively produces is a
list of a whole bunch of different
variations of that same part so we've
been able to kind of model that quite
precisely and also model the
relationship between different
variations so the B variation is a
functional composition of the a
variation with an extra split so we're
able to describe kind of the how
music's put together how it's inside
functions so all we do is the part just
brings these all together into this kind
of massive massive data there's two
other parts that function and almost
exactly the same way and they all have
quite a few variations but well that
lets us do is it lets us write a program
that randomly chooses from those
variations which is how a ROM describes
the process and then plays the result so
actually rather than just notating a
particularly example of this being
played this program captures the non
determinism and the iteration so what
this says if you don't read closure is
we take the drums which the child mother
and father part we map random variations
function across it so we randomly choose
and then we concatenate together so we
pick one variation and then pick another
then pick another to play infinitely we
introduced the part successively so not
everyone starts at once because there's
no conductor so the person with the
highest pitched instrument starts and
then the others come in and then we
played at a particular tempo so this is
what it sounds like if you interested
this is time in a cycle at five
so that's quite complex right it's hard
to kind of pick out the individual parts
you can see why if you just heard that
music the first time if you're in Bangui
and you're wrong
that you know you'd wonder well how do i
how do i how do i understand the order
that is present in this music and so
that's kind of where the polyrhythm of
the book comes in so those those
different parts they're kind of playing
competing rhythms there's no they're not
clearly based around the one underlying
one two three one two three they're all
playing off against each other and
that's what creates the complexity over
time and actually you know there's if
you think about how many variations each
individual part has you could actually
play that song for quite a long time
before actually having repetition so you
have this ostinato with variation you
have kind of repetition but kind of
infinite variation kind of vertical
interest so that's our guitar rumor
that's one piece I wanted to relate this
to maybe a more well known piece of
music called clapping music which is by
an American composer Steve rice so a lot
of Steve Rogers music operates by
similar logic to that of the Banda Linda
and other Central African Republican
musical traditions but it produces
variation in a slightly different way so
hopefully this will be readable but this
operates and in exactly the same way as
the music code for the previous piece
it's a program that generates that kind
of JSON data structure so you take the
African Bell pattern which is something
that's a kind of a widely used rhythm
you do ostinato which I told you is
repetition so you repeat that over and
over and over again and we're going to
give that to the mother drum and then we
accompany that with another version of
the same thing the African Bell pattern
but every four times we repeat it we add
in an extra note and then we repeat that
forever so what that means is this is
what Steve Raj called is fading
technique so you have two parts and one
is gradually slipping out of phase with
the other and this is actually something
that's quite closely related to the
earlier music applied and rushes
specifically
been influenced by a rom maybe not for
this piece but overall his sights are
wrong as an influence
so here's Steve Rogers clapping music
that's the rhythm this is the better
time
in both parts
so God is constantly evolving rhythm as
the as the two copies are the same
rhythm slowly slide
so I was in two minds actually whether
to play that cuz it's definitely like
related musically but one of the things
that I'm afraid of falling into the trap
is the same one as we discussed with
Bartok earlier which is I kind of
inadvertently told you you should care
about this Central African music because
it's been blessed by attention with the
western composer right so there's a kind
of a Bhakra see there in that so there's
are the same problem of appropriation
that when when people gain inspiration
from music from other cultures that's a
great thing and it's not kind of in
itself bad but if it means that the
original source of the music is lost
that that's a pity key that's that's not
that's not right
so so if I would just talk about
percussion so things that don't have a
picture at least they do have a pitch
but that pitch doesn't really play a
function in the music so what I want to
talk about it a little bit more is that
second piece I said I'd simulate which
is the wind instruments with the 20
players playing one note each so we need
pitch for that because they each have
one pitch but before I get to there we
have to develop our model of music a
little bit more so I'm gonna talk about
scales hopefully this will be this will
make sense to folks so what I want to
get to the point is where the scale of
the music that I'm modeling I want to be
able to describe that with the natural
numbers I want to be able to say you
know play the first note second note
third note of that scale so if we look
just at the the paragraph I've just
highlighted there that's a way of
notating the a major scale which I'll
just play and I think I'm actually not
that happy with that so far right so if
you look at the raw frequencies they
kind of seem arbitrary the structure
inherent in the frequencies of this
scale I'm not at all visible right sorry
if I'd made a mistake and it's not 554
it supposed to be 564 it'll be really
unobvious in this structure so there's a
lot of potential for me if I was working
with raw frequencies of the notes to
have like my own B semi flats right
where I introduce things that aren't
supposed to be there or I miss things or
I make a mistake it's not it's not a
very good demonstration of the
of the other music that we're talking
about and it's it's also maybe if you
think in terms of type system it makes a
lot of illegal states representable
right there's a lot of states that
aren't notes in the scale that are just
able to be able to be notated there so
if I just went you know 564 like it
would be really hard to know so what we
want to do is we want to use programming
to index into that scale so that we can
represent it with the natural numbers
and so we can we can take care of just
what the notes we want to play and the
model takes care of mapping that onto
the actual frequencies so one way of
doing this that gets as part of the way
is MIDI so media is a way of numbering
each of the keys on a piano basically so
what we've got here we look at this this
other version is almost exactly the same
as the one where we notated the raw
frequencies except we're modeling it a
bit better so if we have notated the
frequencies using MIDI codes 69 71 73
these are the numbers of the piano keys
that correspond to what we want and then
we use a function NIDA Hertz to map back
to the frequencies so that does a little
bit of exponential maths it's kind of
quite easy if you want to look into it
but basically all we need to know is we
can now work in MIDI rather than wall
frequencies and so our model is a little
bit better and now we have fewer illegal
states we can represent because we're
only working in MIDI we're not going to
accidentally create a B semi flat so it
should sound exactly the same but it's
still a little bit arbitrary so I said I
wanted to use the natural numbers but
this is starting just kind of randomly
like halfway between zero and a hundred
like what's special about that and if I
as it happens if I tried to play a zero
MIDI it would just be really low and
kind of that's not where I want to be in
the scale so I still haven't got the
model quite right because the natural
notes of the scale are kind of way up
there offset so I can do a little bit
better than that which is I can create a
another function with represents the
different keys and all this function
does is it represents that offset so the
key of a is just a function that adds 69
to a relative MIDI to give an absolute
MIDI so what that means for how I can
notate things
is that I can now just specify starting
from zero so I can specify the a major
scale but with zero to four rather than
69 71 73 or whatever so if I play this
again should this have made a mistake
should still work the same and the way
that I've then converted back is I've
just got the functional composition of a
which adds 69 to everything and MIDI to
Hertz which maps it to the frequency but
still you might notice that there are
still illegal states that I haven't
excluded like one doesn't appear in this
scale and it actually shouldn't be there
if I may go play one and we'll see how
it should sound a bit weird the first
three notes yeah so my model still
allows for that so if I go to scales
what scales do is they represent the
patterns between the allowed notes so a
major scale has a gap of two or a jump
of two from its first to its second note
so we skip one note we skip another note
we don't skip skip skip skip we don't so
these these twos and ones here represent
the difference between successive notes
in the scale and plane so with that I
can actually finally play the natural
numbers so now I'm just playing the
pictures from zero to seven and because
I've got my functions that I've composed
together at maps properly into the scale
so this is great but so far I'm only
dealing with what are actually western
music scales so there's seven note
scales major and minor what European
music is written in but actually the
reason the whole reason why I introduced
this topic is that the Central African
music of the Banda Linda that Aram talks
about don't use these scales and so
actually western music notation kind of
has an embedded assumption will be using
scales like this with seven notes in but
we can do a little bit better and we can
shape a notation for this particular use
case so they use descending pentatonic
scales so rather than having jumps of
one and two between notes they have
fewer notes they have five of them and
they have jumps of two or three
so this is what the pentatonic scale
should sound like it kind of has a bit
of a different feel to it and so now
what I'm doing is I'm using the natural
numbers still but I'm indexing into a
pentatonic scale so I'm I've got a good
model but it's of a different
alternative scale so that's one thing
too fewer notes the scale so to two
states that were representative in the
major scale that I've now excluded
because I don't you are not used in this
music but the other thing that I think's
maybe a more interesting aspect of
Central African music is scales are
thought of in the reverse order so in
western music we start low and we build
up through the scale to get high and
that's how I've played all the scales so
far but as Central African music
musicians conceptualize music they don't
think of low and high frequency they
think of small and big sounds that's how
that people's mental model of the music
works so you start with the smallest
sound made by the smallest instrument
and then you progressively move to the
big sounds so you could say they think
in terms of wavelength where as European
music thinks in terms of frequency so in
the end the same thing but kind of a an
inverted way of approaching approaching
it so what I can do is I can produce a
descending scale just with another
function stacking this this thing so
what so now if I play a descending a
pentatonic so I can play the natural
numbers but now it actually plays an
appropriate scale for this kind of music
so the reason why I've brought all that
up is what I want to do is I want to
play a wind instrument piece that has
pitch and I want to use that model of
the scale to represent how the pitch is
going to work so Nigeria Bell and or Oh
which I'm sure I'm pronouncing
completely wrong is a piece for 18
musicians each of which has a pitched
instrument so the model they have is
much the same as the drum piece so we
have a basic model which has pitch time
and duration now
and it also has variations so we have
the same kind of variation the a
variation is just by splitting a note
the B variation is a composition of the
a variation and splitting another note
we've actually got a couple of other
concepts as well here so there's a
there's a concept of an accent note
which I said they could only play one
pitch there's actually a way that the
musicians can play like a slightly
higher note just to give what they're
doing emphasis and I've also got the
concept of skipping a note which is
self-explanatory so just like I did with
the drum parts he is four different
variations on the same horn theme and
that the same process goes for the tar
the higher the Cholula and the Bongo
which are parts in this in this
particular piece so before I play the
piece as a whole what I want to do is I
want to just play their first individual
single part which will give you a little
bit of an insight because once we play
the whole thing like a ROM you'll
probably struggle to to pick out the
individual detail and you're just kind
of you'll be you'll hear the
overwhelming mosaic of how it put
together you won't hear the individual
parts so so here is just just the t/ta
part right so bear that in mind that's
what an individual musician is doing
when we when we come to play the whole
piece so now we're put together the the
first five parts so they each of these
have one note in a pentatonic scale and
like the other music we're gonna
introduce it successively so the person
with the highest note is the leader and
then everyone follows the person who has
the the higher instrument than them oops
so what I didn't do it I didn't really
wait so now well now it's turn up again
right introducing new part
I think it sounds quite pleasant but
those harmonies aren't European Harley's
they're not they're not made in the same
way that European music is made and it's
kind of quite I find actually kind of
hard to imagine playing that music
myself just hitting that one no
naturally in between all the other notes
is kind of it it's almost a percussive
way approaching music and but I said
yeah I said there was going to be 18
musicians and that was just five so you
might wonder where where are the other
13 right so basically with scales when
you go through say the five notes of a
pentatonic scale or the seven notes of a
hepta tonic scale what you end up doing
is kind of wrapping around so you you
have a new note that so it's just a
higher or lower version of the other one
and that's how that the Banda Lindell
music works as well so what I'm going to
do is I'm going to introduce big
versions of all those five parts and
all-big is just a it's just a function
that goes through a num and lowers the
frequency of all those by an octave I'm
gonna do big-big so trying to use being
just try to you know get in the mind so
that these are about bigger sounds not
about lower sounds and there's actually
even like a few notes that have big big
big versions of three of the three of
the horns so if we play this what we'll
end up doing is successively bringing in
all 18 musicians and you'll and you'll
hear the effect that's you've heard it
just kind of in one version there but
you should also if you concentrate on
different parts of the scale you should
be able to hear those kind of repetitive
rhythms like all throughout the nose age
that's the top you see another one
and unlike music European music it
doesn't really have a well-defined
beginning middle and end right so what
that will continue until the master of
the horn says okay well I give a signal
maybe like a Samba band or something
like that okay now we finish up so it's
really quite a fascinating piece of
music and this is this is a little bit
of it written out in western music
notation and you might think that's
that's not the whole piece that's
actually just a two and a half around
because each of those individual lines
is actually a separate notation for each
individual part so I would claim that
this doesn't really express a lot of the
structure of the music that we've been
able to do in code it's kind of and two
angles that doesn't one of which is this
doesn't represent that kind of non
determination non determinism in
repetition but as part of the mechanics
of how the music actually comes to life
the other thing is that this does this
this is still built around hepta tonic
scales so there's like two notes of the
scale that aren't notated there but you
couldn't tell just really by looking at
it there's a couple of lines that if you
put a dot on it you would have actually
made a mistake because music is built
for European music the music notations
built for European music so I'm just
going to quickly finish up with a bit of
the philosophical implications by using
this way of representing music so this
is really a process of compilation so we
want to have an expressive notation but
we want to have a simple kind of in
format that we execute so that's not
that dissimilar to you know Grace
hoppers work and you know cobalt goes
all the way back there maybe a more
recent relevant example is to think
about how Java closure Scala
Frigga other jvm languages all combined
at compile down to the same bytecode so
you have the ability to have very
different ways of looking at the world
models notation but you can you can
compile it down to a common point so you
you almost have like a mutual
intelligibility you can have interchange
between this languages you can have an
understanding of stating what closure
does in terms of Scala and maybe a more
relevant example for the music I've done
so far as omitting OSC messages from
overtone submitting open sound control
messages
that's a data format I found a really
good quote and this is thanks to Tommy
Hall who gave a talk actually based on a
similar pattern but with talking about
puppet and had a provision
infrastructure as code which is the
language should represent the data
should be a simple data only format and
programmatic modification of this data
should be done in a real programming
language so it always sounds literally
about what we're trying to do with music
but this is about you know Borg Omega
and kubernetes so this passion of having
a rich programming language that emits a
model is quite an interesting one so you
might ask well if we've represented
music as code does that mean we've like
purged the cultural bias because you
know lambda calculus is like universal
right well not quite right so algorithms
encode bias so it might make it easier
to spot that you've put that there but
it doesn't you know it doesn't it
doesn't eliminate it and one good
example is why I I have chosen not to
synthesize the choir music so in a
language that's a tonal language the
actual meaning of the lyrics and the
melody are intrinsically coupled so I
didn't actually feel that the data
format that I had was actually good
enough to include all the relevant
characteristics of vocal music maternal
languages the people writing this stuff
of Western so the most problematic thing
about this book for me even though I
loved it is that the musicians from the
Central African Republic aren't named
the people who are named are other
Western academics that aroma is either
agreeing or disagreeing with so that's
kind of a bit uncomfortable to me
and maybe this way of stating music is a
Western can see so this kind of context
lists representing of music as pieces of
data and isolated kind of dots floating
in space well that's not necessarily
that authentic a way of understanding
this music most of the music in this in
this book have cultural functions
they're done to celebrate certain things
or when certain things happen so I kind
of like lost all that meaning and it
might be an easy way to think about it
if you're a westerner would be if I
asked you explain what the wedding match
means if you just told me the chord
progression you probably would have
missed a lot of the detail of it so I
think that using computational
ethnomusicology which is the
slightly academic term for this might
give us a better way of articulating the
models in the understanding we come to
but it doesn't really do anything to fix
the bias in the framing of our questions
so it's a good step but it's not it's
not a free ticket out
so in conclusion rather than using a
score as a model which is both a
notation and a representation if we can
split those two things into into a
program that can be expressive that
generates representation that can be
basic then we can have many notations
for one representation so that we can
understand the relationship between our
notations so we can understand the
relationship between how we're phrasing
Western music and how we're phrasing
different kinds of central African music
and the notation can be really
customized and specific we can induce
stuff into it but it's just for the kind
of music that we're looking at now
because we don't have to worry about
burdening the language with stuff that's
irrelevant for most most use cases we
can actually just build in stuff for
that specific instance which is really
useful and the representation can be
really generic and simple because it's
compiled so we can reuse infrastructure
like the synthesizers and more more the
point we it gives us a point of mutual
intelligibility between the musics so I
would say that as programmers we have
sophisticated mechanisms for abstraction
so kind of pulling things apart and
Composition putting them back together
again which lets us us achieve open
world languages that have mutual
intelligibility and I think that's a
very interesting area for people who are
trying to represent different musical
systems to explore thanks very much
do I have any time for questions or is
there any any questions anyone has sure
yeah yeah
yes
Yeah right so that is actually an
element for the model I didn't include
so you've so the question was do the
frequencies that I played in the final
piece exist on Western scales so they're
simple and slightly wrong answer is yes
because the pentatonic scale is
basically major scale but with notes
missing but the slightly more correct
answer is that the temperament of
Central African music is an equal
temperament so it's so I've used just
for simplifications sake I've used an
assumption that all notes are kind of
equally spaced across the frequency
spectrum and that's not actually true
for Central African music so if I were
to do it maybe a little bit more
authentically then we'd be having
slightly different frequencies in the
raw output and that's actually a really
good advantage to using music as code
because it lets you represent that but I
didn't include that oh that bit in the
talk today yeah that's a good question
no I haven't yet I hope that I if
there's anyone here today who's from the
band to Linda then that would be really
welcome but no I haven't so my
validation and you're right that this is
kind of hypocritical because it doesn't
match the standard set by a ROM in the
book is to compare it to recordings of
that of that tradition so I guess if I'm
missing something then I would also be
missing it when I'm checking the results
so yeah that that's a very problematic
part of it yeah yeah yeah
yes to walk you air to signal you out
alright I'll play it again when we can't
do that sure yeah
anyone else oh yeah right um so
basically I saw that the question was
could I briefly say technically what's
happening when I push the button right
so I'm what I'm using is I'm using
closure and I'm using a vim plugin so
I'm executing code from inside them
which is kind of just a nice workflow
specifically I'm using a system called
overtone which is a JVM wrapper for the
supercollider synthesis server so what's
happening is we generate this sequence
of notes and then that's a lazy sequence
that the underlying infrastructure is
just pulling out examining and sending
to supercollider one at a time so it's
actually like there's not very much
there the code for this is all online as
is the slide so if you wish to
investigate further you can alright yeah
yes oh so it just from my examination
that so the question was when the split
happened what was I actually doing so
it's just a relatively simple function
that seeks out a note and produces two
new notes with a break in the middle
because yep so there was one and then
there's two because most of the
variations can be kind of explained
simply as just kind of adding in extra
notes
all right probably trying to finish up
now Thanks